- 2019 for me is the year of Facebook.
Like, I'm gonna go all in on Facebook.
(electronic music)
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
Hey everybody, in today's
vlog, I crush it in Phoenix,
get on a plane and go to Atlanta,
and go in studio with an
artist that I think is next.
Hope you enjoy the show.
LinkedIn content, organic, is probably
the best platform for
organic besides Instagram,
and I think Instagram's
on the beginning stages
of like, starting to
lose it's organic value.
I'm starting to believe that everybody
has to have a LinkedIn strategy.
I even told Jordan, who's a
personal trainer, this morning,
I'm like, you need to start
making LinkedIn content,
things like "five minute
workouts at the airport,"
because that's what
business people would like.
Hey guys, so in Phoenix,
during strategy sessions,
I kind of really brought it.
Caleb, my guy here, let
me study here, Caleb.
Caleb here is trying to figure
out how to break it down.
So I'm introing him, he will post-produce
and figure out how to path you after this.
Hope you enjoy the vids.
- Here is like, the story
of literally the moment
that the economy collapsed in 2008.
And I think there's really
good moments to learn from.
Definitely take note, and
watch it two or three times.
- I woke up in the morning that day.
I was in France, buying wine,
and Brandon calls me 'cause it's,
you know, it's six hours ahead there,
it happened in the morning.
Brandon calls me and goes,
"Hey," I was like, "Hey."
He's like, "We've had like $400,000
"in pre-order wine canceled this morning."
Like literally, I remember where I was.
I started buying less wine
like than I did the first
two days of the trip.
You know, first two days of the trip,
I'm a bigshot, like yeah. (slurps)
I'll take 100 cases of that,
I'll take 50 cases of that.
Literally an hour later, I'm like,
"Yeah, this is not that great.
"Thanks for your time."
So yeah, bro, I would highly,
and listen, you're no dummy.
And I don't know, I would've said
the same thing a year ago
and nothing's happened.
Well actually, something has.
Listen, Facebook's collapsed.
I've lost a lot of money in
the last, you know, like...
But I'm gonna buy, and because,
my big thing is, debt is awfully scary
if your business doesn't do
well when the economy collapses.
If yours does, look, I
think VaynerMedia explodes.
I do, because I think when
Aquafina wakes up and realizes,
and it happens in a day, remember.
Takes 30 to 60 days for
it all to get figured out,
but it happens in a day.
And when they get in a board meeting
on March ninth, and are like,
"Okay, we had 83 million
in marketing this year.
"Now that's been cut to nine million.
"What are doing with that money?"
"I have a funny feeling
that Gary V character
"might know what to do with it
"way better than fucking
Madison Avenue student
"who's critiquing me, and so
I think we're gonna explode."
Look, if we were partners, I'd be like,
bro, honestly, here's my plan.
It's been so good for so long.
Let's actually be humble as fuck.
Let's just actually hoard cash.
You have to understand,
a million dollars in
your bank account today,
in the world, vs. what
happens when the world melts,
that million's worth like four.
And so like, it'll suck
right now, it sucks for me,
I'm sitting around and just watching,
sitting on cash, being like, I'm an idiot.
Like, right?
But I won't be at some point.
It's gonna happen, it's no different than
in a 50 year window, I don't give a shit
if it takes another four years.
Especially, and this is how I hedged it,
because I'm building a machine
that capitalizes on the other side.
So I would actually tell
you, try to think about that.
- This is a moment where Gary
talks about the dangers
of living in the middle.
And how he believes on
living in the extremes.
- One thing I'm obsessed with is extremes.
If I started an events business,
if I was like in the
blow-up castle business,
to rent to like bar
mitzvahs and birthdays,
what I would do tomorrow
is go to fucking China
and make the most extreme
castle of all time.
Like, a 900 foot castle.
Because what's happening
in our society right now
is it's minimalism and it's extremism.
The middle's fucked.
So I'm very hot on like,
if you look at like the
pop-up museums in New York,
it's like extreme candy, extreme colors.
It's like, you've got these you know,
mocktails that are like 39
dollars, but they steam out,
like, go extreme as
fuck 'cause the picture.
It's the club dynamic.
Why do clubs right now have,
when you order the champagne,
the sparklers come out and...
People want attention.
They're not buying the champagne,
they're buying the attention.
They want every dude and
girl in the cLub to look,
and be like, oh, that's the big-baller.
Any way you can figure out to be
the most extremer or the most subtle.
Don't live in the middle.
The world is getting pulled that way
because of the internet.
The middle's bad, it's really huge.
And then, look at yourself
and figure out who you are.
The reason I think I work
is I'm a little bit of both.
I'm very outlandish in
my communication style,
but I'm very minimal in my like, right?
There is no jewelry, that's what you said.
Like that's not who I am.
And if I was, that's
cool, I love authenticity.
Andy Frisella loves
Lamborghinis, for real.
And so, that's cool,
and he can afford 'em.
And he's not renting 'em to look cool,
to like, make you pay for
a thousand dollar course.
So like, that's authentic.
Authenticity, end, left
or right, no middle.
- And as the last one from
this strategy session,
Gary talks about his move on Facebook,
how he feels like
attention's moving from it
and so he's going all
in on it, check it out.
- Something I'm super excited about
is telling Jordan, while I
was working out this morning,
I texted Andy yesterday,
2019 for me is the year of Facebook.
Like, I'm gonna go all in on Facebook.
'Cause everyone's kind of phasing out.
And I'm gonna produce original content,
which is unusual for me
for the last couple years,
strictly for 50 to 90 year olds.
Strictly.
Original content just
for 50 to 90 year olds.
Because I think it's gonna
be very fertile grounds
for Facebook next year.
'Cause I think a lot of the
best people are leaving.
'Cause they feel like it's
not as good, it's not as cool.
It's, you know, Instagram.
And it just, it's the
way I think about shit.
It's like, right?
Facebook, are you 49 years old
and in a great place in your
career and it's working,
whether you're an executive
or you have your own startup,
and it's going extremely well?
You're making more money than
ever, or on the verge of?
You're making bigger impact,
it's growing, everything's right?
Except, you have
five-year-old Charlie at home?
You have six-year-old Susan at home?
I just really desperately
need you to understand
that if you're 51 years old right now,
and everything's going great,
and you've worked so hard for it,
but you are self-aware enough
to know that you need to be
at these recitals and these ball games
and you wanna milk when
they get home from school.
That it is remarkably right
to take the foot off the pedal
for 12, 13, 14 years,
because they're gonna be
running off to college so damn quick.
And let me remind you, here
in this video, Facebook,
that 63 years old, 51 plus 12,
6-year-old, 12 years, going to college,
that 63 years is a goddamn baby
when it comes to business, and
you have 20 incredible years
of career, startup, your
mission, your desire.
If you're self-aware enough to know that
you need to take the pedal off the metal
and spend more time at home, go do that!
Deploy self-awareness,
there is no right way.
There is no proper work-life balance.
If that's what you need, not
because your spouse said it,
or because your friend said it,
or your mum's got eyes for you,
or a motivational post on Instagram,
because that's what you know
about yourself, then go do it.
And the same point, if it's not,
then triple down on that thing.
Work-life balance is individual.
But understand that life is
much longer that people recognize.
It is definitely the shortcoming
of the majority of people.
You can't put time in perspective.
So take the foot of the pedal.
If that's what's in your heart now, do it.
The trick, the unlock, the
place that you will hear
an enormous amount of
pontificating, for me, in 2019,
will be around the volume of content
that you produce for the 10 platforms.
Over the last year, what has become
unbelievably obvious to
me, that works for me,
thousands of other people, and
the brands that are winning,
in society, the businesses
that are growing,
the one correlation that's
just black and white to me.
(electronic music)
I just want to maximize the time
before I have to catch
this flight to Atlanta,
so thank you for listening.
If you don't have a very serious
LinkedIn content strategy,
you're leaving a huge opportunity.
You're a young dude, and you're gonna
gravitate towards IG video, easy,
but LinkedIn is fucking gold right now.
For everybody, LinkedIn organic reach
is more similar to what
Facebook organic reach
was doing five or six years ago.
It is just an opportunity.
And I don't care if you're
selling weird tee shirts.
Figure out how to make it
business-oriented, in LinkedIn.
Everybody here should really think about
how to make their content
work to professionals.
If you're in the roofing
business, like, title the post,
"Why Lawyers and HR
Executives Need Better Roofs."
I'm not joking.
So for you, bro, heavy
content on LinkedIn,
before LinkedIn's organic
reach starts declining too.
Where I've made my money
and where I've lost my money
is on the delta of the
two things that matter:
the idea, and then the
timing of that idea,
which you're gonna deal with with AI.
And then honestly, the thing that
in the beginning I was great at,
but then I did get a little too
high on my supply off the winds,
and I started just betting on the idea.
I was at my best, and I'm
back to being that person
when I bet on the person, too.
Like, I can't, I would look the other way.
You know what I did poorly?
I would hear a business idea,
and I could dream what I
would do if I was running it,
and that's when I
thought it would be good.
But I didn't realize,
like, I'm not running it.
And so, what makes a
success, in my opinion is,
I believe in the idea, the
idea's timing is right.
Because that's where people get killed.
Like, AI's gonna happen, when?
AR is gonna happen, when?
You know how many people
poured tons of money
into virtual reality, 18 months ago?
We're not even close, nobody here uses VR.
Like so, timing, idea, human.
Thank you, everyone.
(electronic music)
Alright guys, gotta go, see ya, bye!
- My boy!
- My guy!
- How you doing?
- How are you?
- Oh, good.
- What's up man.
- My pleasure.
What up, man, how are you?
♪ Ridin' through the hood,
got that strap, yeah ♪
♪ Chanel britches, check
the pants, check the gear ♪
♪ Got a bad lil' bitch,
ass fat, waist slim ♪
♪ Bust another play, nigga
eatin' good over here ♪
- It's just obvious that
this is gonna happen.
That's what I'm good at,
whether it's Facebook or Gunna,
it's the same shit, I just
understand what America likes.
You know what I mean,
it's just the same shit.
It's gonna happen, it's gonna happen.
You know what I like the most, though?
Like, we look at a lot of stuff.
There's a lot of people who
have sounds that can make it.
It's after I started talking
to both of 'em, really.
And this kid's really got it.
He's got his head on straight as fuck.
- This shit happened so fast, man.
- Which is really why you need
to have your head on straight.
Because when it happens fast,
man, if you're head ain't on
straight, it's over, quick.
Yeah, because money, and
like, fame, and opportunity
exposes what's going on in your dome.
You know?
Every time I hear people like,
"Oh, the money changed him,"
I'm like, ah, you got it
twisted, that's who he was.
He just got exposed, 100%.
♪ No, oh, oh, oh, don't do no playin' ♪
- Like, all these people who tryna
do motivational talks,
like they're just in...
They're comfortable doing
like in that conference room,
but you're in this shit, with Mike.
Mike is like, you know what I'm saying?
I think that shit's crazy.
- Appreciate it, man.
The best part is it feels so real,
it feels so natural to me.
- And then, they gon' love
you more because of this.
- Of course, and I'm trying to help.
I'm not asking for anything,
I'm just trying to give them exposure.
- That's crazy.
- Just giving.
Just rolling and giving.
The authenticity's the
only thing that plays.
Can't walk in that room and be there
to like, fucking do the wrong thing.
You're gonna lose.
- Yeah, just not do shit.
- And not like, and just
like, be out of place,
and not like speak it.
For sure man, you're exactly right.
And the best part is, like,
we're making the documentary.
Like, we're gonna watch this film
in nine and a half years on
Netflix or whatever the fuck,
and be like, you know?
(electronic music)
- Need to get a proper picture of my man.
- See ya, folks.
Great day, it's fucking happy.
Making so much happy, it
just feels exactly right.
Vlog, I love you, thank you so
much for watching this shit.
This journey means a lot,
the feedback, the comments.
Subscribe if you haven't, please.
♪ No, oh, oh, oh, don't do no playin' ♪
♪ No, oh, oh, oh ♪